côté courts l'interrogation oui tout le
monde ne semble pas d'accord sur
l'opportunité de cette réforme
nous avons fait un petit tour de table
en donnant la parole à des instituteurs
des directeurs d'école et des parents
d'élèves
sophie davant le décret transformant les
directeurs d'école en maître directeur
provoque depuis quelques jours la grogne
chez les instituteurs principale crainte
un abus de pouvoir des nouveaux maîtres
directeur nous luttons contre ce que
contient le projet monory c'est à dire
une caporalisation de l'école la
critique du statut des nouveaux maîtres
directeur la première d'une longue liste
de revendications le problème du maître
directeur est un problème réel mais je
crois que c'est aussi la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase je crois que
jamais dans l'enseignement actuellement
on aura été capable d'aligner un nombre
aussi grand de revendications
renforcement de l'autorité du directeur
mise en place d'une formation appropriée
des mesures qui pour cette institutrice
ne peuvent être que bénéfiques pour
l'enseignement et reconnaître une
fonction qui existait des chats qui a
toujours existé sauf que jusqu'à présent
les directeurs avaient toutes les
responsabilités de ce rôle qui est si
important dans les écoles et qu'il
n'était quand même pas reconnu de par
leur salaire qui pour lequel une percée
avec une faible indignité et ensuite il
n'avait pas de formation je pense que
dans ce nouveau projet qu'ils auront une
formation est quand même que
pécuniairement ce qui n'est pas
négligeable le surplus de travail qui
fournit sera reconnue
les avis divergent et également chez les
parents d'élèves mehdi pourrait d'ores
et déjà redouté pour leurs enfants une
extension du conflit si gouvernement et
syndicats ne parviennent pas à
s'entendre et les syndicats 2 les
syndicats ne désarment pas oui ce soir
jean claude barbe